How do you measure a country's power?
By power,
I mean it's ability to impose its will
over other countries.
We could measure their GDP,
their economic growth,
or perhaps even the size of the army,
but I've got another idea.
The best way of showing your power is
forcing other countries as large as
yours to make a big sacrifice.
The sacrifice might be something that
goes against their will,
that they will do it because you want
them to,
well,
this is what trump is trying to do to
the European Union and what is the big
sacrifice that he wants the Europeans to
make it as easy.
He wants them to cut their ties with the
Islamic Republic of Iran.
The question is,
is it really that big of a sacrifice and
most importantly,
Kenny,
when this bat,
well,
these are the very questions we're going
to answer in this video.
Iran is that country.
We've all these independent movies that
yes,
say you're like,
but you've never,
never watched.
Now there is something even more
important to Iran's economy and that's
automobiles.
Yes,
Divya is,
Iran is actually one of the biggest con
manufacturers in all of the Middle East
and I know we have probably thinking
right now,
you're probably thinking you're on ready
Simon Development,
gumtree,
virtually isolated making cars,
but as surprised as you might be,
they even have their own brands.
For example,
the beautiful vehicle that you see here
is the Qataris a mind.
It's a sedan that sells in Iran as a
genre in Russia.
In Venezuela.
Okay,
okay.
You shouldn't have really expected
anything.
Amazing.
The engines are old and the manufacturer
does have a lot to improve,
but I mean,
look,
what can you expect for $700 and
seriously,
we actually think that if you took this
car,
you improve it with a bit of modern
technology would actually be quite a
good deal.
You see,
we actually think that if you took this
car,
improved it with some modern technology,
it would still be cheap and it would
probably be like not a terrible vehicle.
It would probably do really well in
developing markets.
And actually this is why since 2015 when
most of neurons,
all sanctions were lifted,
many European companies actually started
investing in the country.
Great
to enter new joint venture,
right?
Sit
back on the road and your end with deal
to build cars,
but there is a way,
way more than cost.
You see,
the Iranian stock market has a market
capitalization three times bigger than
the Egyptian one and they have all kinds
of companies.
Unlike other oil rich countries in the
region who runs economy is surprisingly
diversified.
Banks,
mining companies and even telecoms all
exist and this what is attracted other
European companies.
Mark's entry into Aren with high web
partnership.
If this wasn't enough,
Iran has a well educated population.
The literacy rate is way higher than
that of Syria,
Iraq and many of the neighboring
countries,
well then 4 million citizens study or
have studied at university and this
means a well trained workforce that can
work for really quite low wages.
Add to this,
the fact that the country has over 80
million people and some of them,
you've actually got a really good place
for investment.
Nonetheless,
this wave of European money has all of a
sudden just stopped.
Yeah,
well,
absolutely sanctioned European companies
that do business with Iran.
But hold on a minute.
I mean,
Donald Trump,
he's the American president.
He can make rules for American.
How many he's all he wants,
but European countries,
I mean,
he's not the president of the world.
How can you impose rules over countries
that he doesn't govern?
Well,
that is another question we're going to
answer today,
but before we do,
as always,
let's take a look back at the history.
Beagle dual in March,
2018 zed te or Chinese phone
manufacturer,
I had to pay a $1 billion fines of the
united.
Yeah.
Why?
Well,
they imported microchips from America
and sold them to Iran.
The White House basically saw this and
said,
ah,
you're doing business with the bad guys.
Now you gotta pay this crazy ass fine or
I'm not going to let you sell your stuff
in my country.
This is a pretty big deal because if you
don't selling in America,
you're not selling in the world's
richest country ever.
It's really not an option.
So he was willing to pay pretty much
anything in order to stay in the market.
And well,
this same thing is happening with many
other company.
Nice.
But as we said,
European companies started doing
business with Iran in 2015 and we're not
talking about buying oil here,
but investments of all kinds.
This is why as soon as trump pasta,
new sanctions,
the EU
for oxygen Europe
requests exemptions from trump's Iran
sanctions for energy aviation and more
basically European leaders wrote a
letter to the White House asking America
to respect to their economic interests.
As you know,
trump isn't a big fan of the European
Union,
so you can imagine is onset.
This is why in 2018 the European Union,
so big action,
it was time for regulation two two seven
one slash nine six oh wait,
you don't know what regulation two two
seven one slash nine six is all about,
oh,
don't worry.
No problem.
That's why I'm here.
You see regulation d two seven one slash
nine six is something like a legal
shield against trade wars.
For example,
let's say this Chevrolet discovers that
Aramco has a factory on Iranian soil.
They could take the French company to an
American court and to make them pay a
fine,
but at that same moment,
the European Union would impose an
equivalent fine on Chevrolet,
but this is still not the end of the
story.
Then suppose Renner says,
hm,
well then I'm going to leave Iran
anyway.
There's too much trouble that,
well,
in that case,
the European Union could also find the
company because technically they are
complying with Washington's sanction.
Yeah.
Say basically all wraps up.
This basically means that all the
companies doing business with Iran are
kind of screwed if they stay.
Washington screws them.
If they leave the European Union screws
them.
It's sort of a really big lose lose and
it's what's known as a political deal.
So the question is now,
who is more powerful?
Who would the European companies prefer
to get screwed by?
Well,
now we're going to see you.
Yeah,
the check.
I'm sure all of you have made an
international transfer at some point.
Let's say you live in Canada and you
need to be paid by an Australian
company.
When you send the invoice,
you don't give you normal bank details
like you'd give to a company in your
country instead of your gift.
This really long number that also has
some letters in it.
Look,
something like this.
Well,
Lee's letters,
all the so called swift.
Yes.
Which system is what banks used for
international money transfers.
It is a network that connects all of the
world's banks.
A number of years around was
disconnected from the swift network,
so this means that even if you wanted to
do business with Iran,
he just couldn't,
after all,
how can you conduct business with
somebody you can't even transfer money
to?
Of course,
could send money in a briefcase,
but that's not very convenient.
In 2015 when that nuclear deal was
signed,
Iran returned to the swift system and
this was the moment.
This was the moment when,
and Ron could go back to the
international business scene.
I know you might be wondering,
well,
who controls the swift system?
Well,
yeah,
absolutely.
You guessed it.
It's of course a company called swift,
the Society for worldwide into bank
financial transactions and guests where
they have the headquarters.
Oh yeah,
it's in Brussels.
So yeah,
I probably know what you're now
thinking.
You're thinking if all of the
international transactions and managed
in a euro,
then America doesn't have to do much to
avoid doing business with Iran,
right?
Well,
no,
not right at all.
Very,
very wrong.
You see,
swift is actually a cooperative society.
This means all the important decisions
made by a board of managers with 25
representatives from the most important.
Thanks
side of this board of managers.
There are two Americans.
One is from Citibank and another is from
jp Morgan Chase.
Two representatives will have to pay
crazy fines if they can't convince their
colleagues to disconnect Iran from the
swift system.
If this happened,
Iran would be isolated from the
international market.
If you can't make transactions,
you can't do business.
It's really just that simple.
This is such an important matter that
the European Union is already trying to
come up with an alternative system for
international transactions.
Something like a modern day barter
system.
They call it spv or special purpose
vehicle.
The idea is that instead of exchanging
goods for money,
Europe wants to pay with credits for
other goods.
For example,
let's say that Repsol a Spanish company
wants to buy oil from Iran.
Well,
instead of paying with cash,
they could pay with an equivalent some
machinery.
Wow.
So now you might,
you're on you.
Well we got rid of the boss system
really long time ago cause something
like this really work today.
Well,
the answer is or any time is going to be
able to tell,
but let's assume that it actually does.
Let's say the companies started using
this spv system to trade with Iran.
So let's get back to our reps.
Will example.
This dinosaur juice they just bought has
to arrive somehow,
right?
Somehow somebody has to put it on a
tanker and take it into Barcelona's
harbor.
Well,
most of the old hangars isn't on the
planet then managed by a Danish company
called nurse Gif and Denmark.
Well that's in Europe,
but hold on a second.
No harbor is going to accept an oil ship
if it's not insured.
And it turns out most of the insurance
company is work with oil tankers are
American or have a lot of interest in
America,
which explains news like this.
Shipping
giant Marishka to abandoned Iran as
threat of sanctions grows.
Other countries like China,
they already found alternatives.
They have enough at stake,
so you convinced them to do everything
they can to keep oil suppliers coming in
from Iran.
It's their sixth biggest providers.
7% of their dynoed juice comes from
Tehran,
the Europe.
Europe is a different animal.
In that case,
Iran isn't important enough to risk so
much on this.
In other words,
if you're up wanted to keep buying crude
all from Iran,
they would have to find one new
transport companies to new insurance
companies and three,
they would have to use bartering.
Yeah,
okay.
I look at anything is really possible,
but so far it does seem that America and
Donald Trump is gonna win this match
against the European Union and all of
this has got a whole bunch of
consequences.
In a previous video,
we talked about what's happening with
the international all markets in the
following weeks.
We want to talk about what's going to
happen to the Uranian regime.
Meanwhile,
the big question is can be sanctions and
the Iranian regime.
How much can all prices go up?
You can write me your theories and in
the following days,
let's have a look and see if they match
with ours.
In the meantime,
do you visit reconsider media?
That's the podcast that provided the
vocals in this episode that were not
mine.
Also,
do not forget brand new videos every
week,
so hit that subscribe button and click
the bell icon so you don't miss out on
any updates.
And if you like this video,
do give it a thumbs up.
And as always,
I'll see you next time.